hi everyone welcome we have Federico
lucha Freddie to talk about there's
plenty of room at the bottom very
exciting give him a round of applause
thank you so as a little bit of
introduction I had the privilege of
spending my entire career in free and
open-source software with rare exception
for academia I am the project management
director force F at Red Hat previously I
was the Ubuntu server p.m. at canonical
and if you go back the decade
I was the dreaded systems management
thar at Sousa the talk has nothing to do
with my day job well I guess it is if
you consider that its storage in the end
but since I was an embedded engineer I
guess that this is my definition of fun
so obligatory disclaimer is that we will
most likely break some hardware while
playing this way and it will come out of
your pocket no liability if you follow
our instructions and stub your toe or
bring about the end of the universe or
break your device which is far more
likely so you have been warned let's get
going we have 60 slides on the demo and
about 45 minutes so we have to run a
little bit the idea there is a processor
in an SD card how could they featured
somebody's blog pretty much went viral
word of web process you could call it
virally blooming once linux was noticed
on the device and hackaday
made it famous lots of blogs SD card
sized almost a Raspberry Pi can we
repurpose the device so the word of web
process that I was describing blooming
once linux noticed on the device so I
noticed that this was going on and I
went to the project for Christmas
that was about four years ago so it has
taken me for a little bit of a ride let
me repeat that as there is always
someone that has no idea what I'm
talking about here's the concept a Wi-Fi
enabled SD card it's meant to
automatically download your pictures
from a camera several models exist we
are after the embedded system in the SD
card the CPU of the card itself were not
running Linux from an SD card we're
running Linux on the CPU of the SD card
it's like the Intel Edison that they
originally promised us except at this
time it's for real
there are copious amounts of Google
Translate we used in the making of this
talk really international effort I would
say I saw blogs in French Japanese
German Korean of course English and
obviously in copious use of Google
Translate results in ensuing hilarity we
explore the limits of machine
translation but usually it's clear
enough to understand what's going on in
there
so the card that I'm looking at
specifically is the transcend Wi-Fi SD
line comes in size from 8 gigs to 32
gigs I prefer them as they are more open
even without hacking there are no
attempts at platform strategies by
adding any middling cloud services that
we do not want no stepping-stone service
that may make things easier to set up
and doesn't and adds another potential
place for your pictures to be in the
software on the trestle card is simple
and not perfect but that's an asset in
this case we will see why so where do we
get these cards you can go to Amazon you
could also try a BAE and they're going
to be between $40 and $60 depending on
scarcity about the price of a Raspberry
Pi and up there are others like the PQ I
err card that are fun
shonali the same the pqi aircard is
interesting because it is actually an
adapter card you can put any storage you
want in microsd format in there and the
adapter actually has the embedded logic
not card itself Toshiba makes another
one and there is also the flu card and
you can carry binaries between them as a
matter of fact when you log into the
system you may notice there is a command
buzz in there but there are no
piezoelectric transducers transducers on
the system so what is that for but if
you look at another one of the cards
that has a piezo so you can learn things
in one card and they are applicable to
another these are all really coming from
the same original odm design that
multiple manufacturers purchased but
we're getting be railed here let's keep
going when the postman arrives this is
what you get we're doing the virtual
unboxing here since this is way too big
to do it live inside the package let's
unbox one a card and adapter the
inevitable legal disclaimer there is no
legal track in this conference otherwise
I would blame them and a microscopic bit
of manual which is actually not bad the
adapter is there because you can write
to the card directly boom by mounting it
on your Mac for example or over the
radio and when you have a file system
mounted to places and you are writing
from two places bad things happen the
adapter signals to the card to disable
the radio so prevent simultaneous writes
from air and local mount of course there
is exactly what we want to do but we
think before we do it we only want to
use the radio so we will assemble it so
that it's not switched off and we'll be
careful about our local mounts so just
what is in there this is an SDHC class
10 device
16 gigs in the one that I'm using here
half and double the size exist this is a
full size SD card picture it is Model Ts
1 6 GW
SDHC 10 you have the slides at the end
so you have all the serial numbers you
don't have to take notes and you can
search for the models but it's fairly
easy to find them even without the part
number so physically breaking into the
device voids the warranty I bet you
didn't see that coming
so exacto knife in our way to success we
slice the card in two and find four
large chips interesting the parts on the
left are just the case nothing too
strange there maybe can be helpful if
you are going to dissect one yourself
incidentally do you see the yellow tab
at the center that is the right protects
which cards have interesting technical
detail there is nothing on the device
reading the state of that toggle the
reason for this is that SD cards work
the way floppy drives do if you still
remember floppy drives in floppy drives
write-protect is implemented on the
device if the drive sends a write the
card will take it just like the floppy
would it's up to the drive to implement
write protect not to the to the card so
the drive will not send a write unless
the toggle is in the right place so
overview of the components from the top
left a trace antenna definitely not 3db
antenna
and not a hundred milli watts of
broadcasting power as the whole card
consumes less than that so Wi-Fi range
will not be per dispatch maximum but
that is okay because we're still beating
the pants off of Bluetooth there is no
internal connector you could try your
hand at adding one or so it doesn't seem
very easy maybe you're a master solder
but assume that if you don't add an
antenna you are not going to get full
Wi-Fi range and I'm ok with that then we
have the Wi-Fi radio chip on the top
left the SOC with the arm CPU that we
are going after right underneath it 16
gigs a flash in the big chip and the
flash controller is lost the last thing
on the right and up top - not up top you
can see the notch where the read/write
tab exists no actual sensing for it of
any kind it's just making space for it
flipside besides the standard SD leads
some of the smaller pads are TX and rx
for a 3.3 volt 38 400 board serial and
knowingly really annoyingly they are not
labeled they labeled resistors we don't
give a whit about so I don't know about
that but on the pqi air card TX and rx
pads are properly labeled so that team
gets bonus points for that if you do
wire the serial you get access to a
welcome figured you boot console if
you're not an embedded engineer you boot
is the bootloader of choice for Linux on
embedded devices it's a very handy tool
to have grub can do quite a few things
today there is nothing compared to what
you boot can do it's like having your
own operating system basically so it is
very handy to have access to that
especially because as you will soon see
the Linux system that come
with the card is severely crippled so it
can be quite convenient incidentally
I've been collecting all of these
details for a survey article that has
been cued now for several years behind
the book I just shipped a book so the
survey article will come out so if you
are waiting until next month or so
you'll get all of these details pretty
printed in nice format alternatively if
you go and hack I would like you to
report what you do so I can add you to
the survey article so choose your path
lazy or hacker just act accordingly what
is in there in the for chips CPU Wi-Fi
module flash controller and storage the
SOC is 32 megabytes of RAM is the
weakest spot on the board very suitable
for embedded use fear not for those of
you who are used to gigabytes of RAM
besides you have lots of storage and you
could expand these 32 Meg's would swap
if the kernel was built with swap
support in the SOC the 8 megabytes of
nor flash are used for the system and
that is why and the system is so
stripped it has to fit in these 8 Meg's
of nor flash that it starts from and it
includes a stripped-down kernel intra
intra Memphis and in and very
interesting compromises were made there
we'll see the details of course there is
a massive amount of storage you could
boot with a small system loop mount a
larger image and truth into it if you
had loop mount in the kernel I see a
pattern here
but we can edit Dimitri Greenberg
documented how to rebuild this kernel
and so we have the instructions on how
to do it
CPU is 200 megahertz saying as some
reports indicate 400 megahertz it's a
typo it's because CPU has 400 Bongo MIPS
they're getting mixed up they are wrong
it's 200 megahertz it's an arm
nine to six ejs an arm nine processor
that is not the cortex a9 it's an arm
nine much older thing a low-cost CPU the
architecture was arm v5 t ej more than
five billion of these were made with ABI
it is a really popular low-cost
processor and it's been in production
for 15 years at least it has interesting
extensions for Java which is the J in
that acronym soup I just gave you
but the JS l runtime requires a license
with arm and it was not included with
the system and besides who wants to do
Java these days
so the core is interesting the
extensions he stands for DSP
enhancements because this was used to
make feature phones once upon a time
Java for giselle the Java extension
makes byte codes usable there is an
instruction
bjx branch to Java switches the the chip
into Giselle state the JVM actually
handles the errors and the traps but the
processor runs Java instructions it's
actually super cool if you are into Java
between 134 and 149 I'm not sure why the
variance of the 203 byte codes in the
spec are implemented if we go back to
the Raspberry Pi the original ARP is
brought Broadcom BCM 28 35 third 28 35
years that is an arm 11 there is an arm
1176 j something but it's it's not too
far off from an arm 9 in fact it's
closer to that than it is to to a cortex
so this is a close cousin of the
original Raspberry Pi so the idea is
that instead of the chip on the PI you
would use the chip on this card
different trade-offs you get built-in
radio lose all the interfaces that the
PI has priced a is about the same
the radio is a fortune ship AF and
something something
it's a Wi-Fi controller it contains a
naturist AR 6003 which is the smallest
or at the time it was marketed as the
smallest Wi-Fi chip you could buy the
smallest Wi-Fi core you could buy
because these things get integrated in
in bigger chips the bit we care about
here is that it does Wi-Fi B G and n
doesn't do bluetooth and that it does do
it with very low power draw it does
about one gigabyte a one megabyte yes
one gigabyte one megabyte per second of
transfer rate so don't think you're
going to saturate anything with this but
it's respectable come on we're talking
about is an SD card running on fumes
here so do not plan to saturate any link
but you can get one megabyte per second
incidentally if you if you feel like
going Turtles all the way down there is
a CPU to control the baseband band radio
an extensor MEPs core inside this chip
when it has 256 K's of ROM and 256 case
of RAM I think I didn't get into this
one could be your next project maybe the
storage is 16 gigs of NAND flash nothing
too interesting but we certainly are not
going to be wanting for storage
definitely not the problem the system
has the flash controller is a silicon
motion to sixty eight to six eight three
to six eight three nothing of interest
here accepted and this is good to argue
licensing or there was a little bit of
annoyance in the community because when
Linux was found here people went where
are the kernel modules so some angry
emails were written some back and forth
and the company published the module
so nothing to get angry about this was
resolved and it's no longer in issue but
the module for where the controller is
not public because kind of like you're
familiar with the discussions about
video chips flash controller drivers
have some kind of secret sauce that the
hardware vendor is wont to keep to
themselves
so the vendor of the design doesn't even
have access to that in practice we don't
care about that module so unless there
is someone here from the Conservancy we
can write that problem off there must be
some IP restriction we don't even know
what it is we have the other modules
which lets us build a new kernel if we
want we can just put the driver in there
for the proprietary part as long as
we're using the same kernel version so
we're okay power disc locks between 0.9
and 1.1 Watts idle in my office with the
radio on it peaks at 1.5 once when
wireless clients connect this is with a
110 volt power supply of course an apple
switched power supply efficient but
still we could try to see if the
conversion is removed what happens
presumably we would consume more power
if we pack the CPU while writing to
flash and doing other crazy things I
didn't do that this is just radio on
with clients connected okay
interestingly I also checked what I just
said to see if I could get better
efficiency with USB power and we can
hardly see a difference 220 milliamps is
about 1.1 vom what's at 5 volts so
pretty much what we measured at 120 so
it caused closely closely matches the
other one and it turns out that Apple
knows how to design switch power
supplies good for them good job so let's
start looking at the software side I'm
going to walk you through what you do to
make this work first so then you
understand what I'm doing when I break
in
and it doesn't sound like I'm just
talking but you can actually follow the
process so how does this all work first
you set up the app on your phone then it
gives you access to basic setup and core
functionality setting up network mode
names password shoot and view here
the second option means putting the
phone in monitor mode of sorts where you
take pictures with the camera and they
appear on your phone so you can use them
on the phone as a monitor there is this
automatic download mode and this will be
important to later it also offers you to
upgrade the firmware usually this is a
concern in hacking talks because the
precious security hold used for routing
well maybe disappear that is not the
case this time it does not matter what
version of the firmware you have your
going to get around it so don't worry
about it the latest version is as open
as the first it is good and bad I guess
I say it is good because it lets us hack
the card the security issues we bring
about are not about the hacking of the
bsp but we'll get into that in a second
by default the system wants to be its
own access point great very convenient
for development but not so for photo
download think of it you want to switch
ApS on your handheld device every time
you want to sync pictures the seamless
internet AP client mode is a great
strength of this card for ease of use
compared to others that make it
needlessly more complex by putting in
their service in the middle here you
just choose the mode you want and you
get it no but no need to reach to
mysterious endpoints in the internet so
when it is up it shows here from another
machine in the same room your SD card
has now become its own access point ok
what next
well now you can connect to it just like
you would anywhere else and now you can
ping it just like any other host
so let's look at how it works before we
you know we break into it think about it
the app needs to find where the heck the
card is it is out there on the access
point but at what I P address the card
broadcasts on UDP five five seven seven
seven and here I'm here me I'm here
other cards are even more aggressive
there is one of the models that I
mentioned that belongs in the Hall of
Shame it Arps the entire slash 24 subnet
and found in doubt where every node is
then sends HTTP requests to every live
node and continues until it gets an
answer then maybe it stops me most of
the time it stops don't worry we can fix
this it's just funny the tools are only
needed for initial IP discovery and
password setup if you do not want to use
these tools the card comes with a
convenient default user admin with
password one two three four five six
seven eight
but that's not the part that will make
you laugh we port scan the card to see
what's going on in there
here we see telnet because they already
cracked this one HTTP server the
pictures are published there the app
just HTTP gets them from that web
service a web server services are
offered as CGI scripts in another path
of the web server that's how the app
commands the card to do things the
additional port five five six six
broadcasts new entries and shoot and
View mode if you are connected there you
will get a new URL message for every
picture one lines and your URL new URL
so the app just parses that path that's
how shoot and view works very simple
architecture not bad a few quirks it
downloads pictures twice doesn't
generate thumbnails so it downloads the
picture once it's something L and then
downloads it again it is brightly it
also assumes you are not downloading
multiple pictures at once which are not
so simplicity prevails no complaints you
can browse the HTTP the cards HTTP
server direct
it's a boy our web server exposes
directory listings in theory it should
show you only the directories providing
data and simple CGI being scripts to set
configuration these are in Perl the apps
simply downloads the files and call CGI
scripts and these scripts are the way in
because we can crack the scripts that's
how the card was broken into
so all starts with Pablo who thinks
there must be a CPU in these Wi-Fi
enabled cards turns out he is right
Pablo went out and started poking at the
software looking for security holes find
several the size of a small barn found
dot dot slash dot dot slash back paths
breaking out of a loud area it extracts
files exploits pearl hole and then it
goes and I went in that way myself the
first time but there is a better way
I called orang dot SH I think you know
where this is going write a file to the
SD card named Aaron SH the system will
read it and execute it with root
privilege at boot so all I have to do is
just go telnet please and telnet arrives
so much nicer now the security freaks
among you will be horrified by in terms
of actually working with the card this
is fantastic it makes it so nice there
is another part of this that is
humorously named
I know what you're thinking but that's
not it it stands for firmware update
it's a cover mechanism you supply auto
run dot outer and underscore F you SH
and three files in it Rd kernel program
bin the system starts program bin turns
out this is a copy of the cards you boot
with the default script script loads a
new system onto the old and then reboots
nice way to prevent breaking it also
resets all configuration to the false
which may be handy if you did something
wrong it is a nice way to revert
breaking and also gives you a way back
to the defaults you can fix software
screw-ups you cannot fix the hardware
screw ups but so this is nice
so it's time to try and do this live
we'll skip the unboxing in the interest
of times as we already saw the pictures
we'll just set one up so I had to find a
USB adapter that would not turn off the
SD card radio and so I conveniently went
to my local computer store bought every
single adapter in existence and after a
few tests I returned nine out of ten and
I found this one that actually does
exactly what we need and if the demo
gods are on our side we should be able
to connect unfortunately I cannot show
you the Mac menu and on that point I
don't think it lets me oh it does
alright let's see if it comes up
so then we have an IP address let's see
I typed this recently so let's do that
and in we are so this boots really fast
which is why we don't see anything if we
were on the serial port again same thing
we'll just get the connection it would
beat our ability to connect faster than
it boots the boot is basically
instantaneous now I do my oh this is
nice
usually I have to type this turn
backwards so let's see if we have tab
completion we do yay
so this is pretty much reflects what we
discussed colonel to 6:30 to this is one
of the most popular kernels ever this
shipped in rl6
SUSE Linux Enterprise 11 sp1 and I think
we're going to server 1004 also don't
quote me on that there's a one of the
most popular kernel ever is because the
kernel community had this little
conspiracy let's ship the same kernel so
we can share maintenance effort now this
is the vfat partition this is the 16
gigs and we can put all sort of stuff in
there you can see that I mounted it on a
Nikon camera you can see that I have
proper version of busybox that is not
crippled like the one that's in the
system but I don't have the time to show
you the alternate busybox I'm just going
to show you the system as is rather than
the system the way we want to make it
but we can execute that busybox and
suddenly we will have a full busy boxing
bar environment now this is the
partition that we don't want to corrupt
if you have this mounted on a computer
and over the radio this is the place
where the double writing happens so you
want files here and then you want to
loop mount those files so you agree with
other agents talking to this file system
that that file will be left alone that
there it could be one reasonable way to
do it then once you have a wrong
keyboard once you have a working busybox
you can use the NTP module so that it's
not 2012 anymore and then that gives you
the ability to do SSH because your
certificates are not coming from the
future anymore so you can make it work
just by adding busybox this way or
rather make it work more nicely but you
can also do more so these are the
partitions that you see the jmf s2 is
the is the 8 gig nor the 8 mag nor
partition that the system comes from it
used to be a very popular file system
for embedded work I don't know if it is
anymore since now I'm a manager so I
don't do such stuff but in the last
decade we would always do jmf s2 for
embedded systems so apparently the trend
continues the other stuff is irrelevant
what else do we have we have Y - add
that I have that I don't have Java
because I have Perl 514 that's actually
not bad not too old then we can look at
what's running here so we have the UDP
SVD process which is the one that spans
the subnet as I described before there
are two of them telnet we started it so
we're guilty about that one boa is the
web server servicing serving everything
out and exposing the cgi scripts there
is actually a DNS a dynamic DNS
announcement and there is a DHCP because
we have to serve IP addresses when we
are in access point mode where else is
there the bodyguard process that you see
in there is the one that turns off the
radio when
you plug it in to an SD Drive what else
let's keep the message that's to my cm
proc cpu nothing too surprising here I
got it looks like I got the CPU
architecture right which is not hard
because it's such a common chip and it
is 400 Volga mips
so there you go let's see what do we
have there the one that makes me sad
so we want to loop and we want swamp
that's what's missing here and gives you
an idea of how strapped for space they
were how often do you see swap compiled
out of the kernel but we can fix that
and then finally we can list the network
interfaces of your SD card even though
it seems like completely wrong thing to
do there is nothing there but it's kind
of cool all right let's go back running
a little bit behind so actually
presentation lost the clock see seven
minutes actually no twelve minutes
perfect so as I said before the system
mounts the flash partition under mount
SD so if anything that runs in the
system run rights to mount SD and other
processes right to mount as the mounting
it elsewhere bad so don't do that it's
very easy to fix you can just reformat
the filesystem but you don't want to do
it when your actual application is
running there if you do it during
development
sure no problem just to rebuild the
filesystem so what do we have to play
with I kind of hinted it kernel module
I'm sorry colonel those three modules
are in there so if you rebuild the
kernel you need to put those modules
back in busybox
with pretty much all the plugins missing
except telnet FTP and DHCP we can fix
that very easily much more easily than
the kernel so what's the solution for
the kernel the kernel is extremely thin
but it boots and that's all that it
needs to do due to the need to fit in
the eight megabyte nor nor flash in the
SOC but once we're there we could loop
mount an image from the V fat partition
root into it and have a much bigger
system we just need to have loop mount
to do this and we want to also add swap
so that we can be a little bit more free
about the fact that we only have 32
Meg's of RAM
we need a new kernel and hacker called
Robert figured out how to unpack the
install files and then Dimitri green
bird rebuilt the entire thing looking at
the Kasem's since this kernel doesn't
have symbols exposed in proc so you have
to do it slightly more painful way so
now this work has been done we can
create the live partition out of a
single file
loop mount fruit into it somebody took
this to the extreme so what they did is
download an Ubuntu 9 point something
image the last version of Ubuntu that is
compatible with this architecture
downloaded it put it in the sdcard loop
mounted rooted forwarded X started
Firefox then complained that was slow
it's not too interesting to run we're
going to from 10 years ago but it's kind
of cool that it could go that far and as
I said where there is peril there is
everything this is arm so you can
cross-compile you can build on the
system you can use I package you can
bring your own language but if you want
to be lazy like any good developer this
is a perfectly viable option possibly
you will not be able to read what you
wrote but that's ok the parallel is also
relatively recent 5.14 the big question
for embedded devices is how do you find
them where is my device and we need to
make it safe or the Internet's you
cannot behave like I described earlier
are paying an entire / 24 maybe you can
but you would have to be Facebook most
responsible people don't do stuff like
that so you cannot use this device if
you cannot tell what IP is at there are
three approaches that are common to work
with this problem one is come on known
configuration always be at the same
address this is what I just did when the
card is an AP mode it is always at the
same address 11 to 54 so I know where it
is I don't need to find it then there is
what the card does natively broadcast
when it is in client mode it advertises
where it is
besides the horror I described earlier
there are proper advertisement protocols
like multicast DNS em DNS is a perfectly
fine way to discover things when you're
on local network the third one is to
announce which is the device itself once
it has a valid network connection sends
out an announcement my favorite here is
to send out an XMPP announcement but you
can use any protocol you want and you
know this is a unicast announcement to a
known endpoint in the internet it's not
a broadcast on the local network I'm not
going to go through all of these there
is an article I wrote for Linux Journal
years ago just search for my name Linux
Journal there are scripts implementing
all of these
strategies already worked out in Pearl
that work on this architecture so just
go and grab the scripts you can also do
it right
so if you're sucker for standards like
some people are right you know rightly
so in this case the right standard is
DNS update RFC two one three six which I
suffered implementing a while ago so you
have a fixed DNS name that this device
always has when it comes online goes to
the interwebs and updates the DNS record
for itself so that it is known where it
is this is also implemented in my linux
journal article it's about 15 lines of
Perl so power may be hard to read but
it's very expressive so let's go back to
the security aspect we were joking about
the fact that it was easy to break in
but realistically this is physical
access we have the card and we can do
things to it there's no way they could
keep us out we can also do it over the
Wi-Fi which is a little bit more
annoying fine that hardly matters what
matters from a security point of view is
that this brings the lost USB key attack
to a new level
typical scenario if you read if you are
an info SEC or if you read Tom Clancy
novels is that if you want to penetrate
somebody's network you lose a USB key in
their parking lot and then somebody
wisely finds it and plugs it where they
shouldn't some malware gets loaded and
whatnot now if you're on a military base
they probably shoot on site when they
see a USB stick laying on the ground but
in most corporate environments people
are still foolish enough that they will
do this and this makes it just worse
because now not only you have installed
some malware on some machine that's on
the inside Network you also have a radio
so somebody could broadcast some of the
data out now the countermeasures to this
are no way different from
the ones that you would use for rogue
access points so rogue access points
usually you have jamming devices or you
have access points that send clever
knacks to any attempt to create a
connection from an unapproved access
point or security for USB keys which
usually involves pouring glue in every
USB ports that people shouldn't be
putting things in and this doesn't
change anything
you can pour glue just as well on the SD
slot nothing here is new and these cards
are not super secure but remember your
security posture needs to be
commensurate to your threat assessment
or to your threat model so if you're a
nuclear power plant okay you need to
plan for this but if the question is
whether people are trying to get your
Instagram pictures okay do they really
want to do and this this badly on the
opportunity side what is the opportunity
here this is a low power system with
vast amounts of storage and wireless
connectivity and really really low power
as in you could power it with the solar
panel and put it up a tree this is the
ideal pirate box data exchange if you
don't know the term pirate boxes device
where people connect when they're in
Wi-Fi arrange and put files or retrieve
files anonymously it's it's a way to
exchange files or a spy that drop if you
want to go back to the Intel metaphor
less ominously you can make a
solar-powered geocache but seriously now
you can realistically put a server in
your wallet or you could even make a
server throw away instead of an LED
throwing or you could put a be a wolf
cluster in a shoebox also I would
strongly advise you don't you could put
it in yes this lot in your car radio if
you have one of those and then when you
drive on up to your driveway the radio
syncs the latest songs and podcasts
automatically
and I'm sure there are other things that
I haven't thought about there is one
limitation SD cards usually have SPI
interfaces and that would be awesome
because SPI means Arduino sadly this one
does not that won't work
but this is nonetheless a very
interesting platform to experiment with
cross-compiling is an option you can
also take the lazy way out and prototype
with Perl I solved the discovery problem
for you you have all the scripts this is
very low cost same cost as the original
pie so you can you have to decide if you
want to trade Ram for very low power and
small format or the other way around I
think it's a fair question it's a very
nice hacking platform transcenders being
very nice to the community we broke this
years ago and they haven't complained
they sued anybody they haven't shut us
out they haven't done anything unto word
we get hardware to play with they sell
more hardware great for everyone the
mechanism we used is part of their SDK
and but the SDK is not public so we had
to discover it the hard way
we need a better distro image is that
the set of the crap that I've shown you
but that is relatively easy to do and
there are some out there and some
initial efforts for someone who has
worked on as many Linux distributions as
I have the state of the images is not
acceptable we can do better but there
are adequate things to at least
experiment so if you come up with new
ideas or on how to use it please send
them to me here's my contact info if you
can find me on Twitter or send me e-mail
remember that speakers are Pavlovian
devices so if you like the talk please
let us know write the talks and comments
submit feedback all of that if you do
something with it let us know so we can
include it in the survey paper slides
will be available and I'm here for
questions if you have any awesome it's a
small token of our appreciation thank
you very much for a good talking big
round of applause
[Applause]